alright so I've spent the better part of
a week editing together my next Doctor
Who list and I was just about to finish
when stuff is coming out of comic con
and I figured most of it I'd be able to
pass on I don't usually talk about
comic-con too much because it's just
it's a flood of stuff usually a fair
amount of it we already knew ahead of
time and it's just confirmation but I do
want to talk about the new Batman V
Superman trailer now I've given some
thoughts about this project in a couple
of other videos before and I'm not
overly excited about it i'm not a huge
fan of the Man of Steel I get word the
idea was coming from and I'm not
automatically opposed to it the
execution I wasn't in love with and
while it's not necessarily the fault of
Man of Steel I've come to like it less
as it's become clear that that is going
to be the template for the entire DC
Universe that mood a very desaturated
lack of life lack of vibrancy lack of
fun but anyway getting back to this
trailer there are some things about it
that actually I like and that intrigued
me I don't think it's unreasonable to
show humanity at least a notable chunk
of it or certain key individuals
definitely being afraid of Superman and
what he can do I think that is perfectly
valid in the way that it was starting to
show it was in a way that I would have
been interesting to see which is that
Superman rises above that he does not
just turn his back on people just
because they don't like him that he's
prepared to fight for a world that
doesn't even want him being you know
that sort of Paragon and he's rising
above all these problems and I was kind
of liking that vibe and then my Kent had
the line of you don't owe this world a
thing which kind of made my brain do
that record scratch noise go wait wait
what and that was just for my toe that's
right we don't do grand hope and
aspiration in this film we do everything
sucks now we do see a pretty decent
amount of Batman in this thing which is
both good and bad for me what I see a
ben affleck and his performance i'm
liking and while i feel that a lot of
the destruction and Man of Steel was
rather unnecessary and rather gratuitous
if you're going to have that level of
destruction it's nice to have it mean
something and obviously it's it's now
panning out
it does mean something it impacts the
world and impacts the story impacts
Batman particularly and I find it
interesting the way that they've gotten
him very personally motivated against
Superman I think that can work that said
I was not loving the fact that we saw
glimpses of Batman's origin and his
parents getting killed for crying out
loud we know this story already don't
even give me flashbacks of it well why
are you eating up screen time on that
seeing glimpses of that just makes me
really worried that what we're actually
gonna get is not a batman superman movie
it's going to be a batman movie with
Superman as the plot driver this is
really first time we've seen more Batman
so maybe just this trailer is highlight
any more but the presence of origin
stuff on Batman even being in the movie
that I don't like that at all we got a
few quick glimpses of Wonder Woman not a
lot to go off there yet the little bits
we get of Lex Luthor I'm up and down on
I think I get where jesse eisenberg's
interpretation is going with the
character I think it could work but that
wig man KITT get rid of that thing I
mean we already know he appears as bald
in the movie where that was released as
a publicity still so why are you
sticking that they don't tell me that's
the one takeaway you're going to take
away from the original Christopher Reeve
Superman movie is to have lex luthor in
a dumb wig that he rips off at the end
of the movie the other thing that makes
me nervous is how many shots we got of
Superman where he looks pissed off and
I'm not gonna say Superman can never get
pissed but I really want to see him be
the Paragon I want to see him be better
and be the thing we should all be
aspiring to and him getting pissed in
leveling a city park is not that but
yeah I mean look at the end of the day I
had more positive things to that I could
pick out of this trailer then out of the
first trailer so I'm I suppose on that
level it's a move in a positive
direction I'm seeing things that maybe
could come into something that would
work for me it's honestly though it's
the overall vibe of the thing that I'm
most worried about and that just is
gonna be what it is and it's not gonna
be what I would prefer it to be and I
guess if I'm gonna go to the theater and
see this thing I've got between now and
when it gets released to try and get my
headspace out of what I wish it was and
try and get more on its level and I
don't know if I'm going to be able to do
that but we'll see I'm assuming that you
have probably seen this trailer too
and whatever your thoughts on it why did
you drop something down in the comments
and we'll talk about it until next time
this council is adjourned